es ist wieder schlimm aber ich kann echt
nichts dran machen seit 1989 sind wohl
drei viertel aller insekten verschwunden
hallo das ist wirklich nicht gut also
fast 30 jahre lang wurden mehr als 50
deutschen naturschutzparks also die
gebiete wo insekten eigentlich besonders
geschützt sind untersucht das ergebnis
ist dabei wirklich katastrophal wie es
dazu kommen konnte und was dagegen getan
werden kann jetzt den klicks und science
fiction herzlich willkommen
ja eigentlich ist es ja gar kein problem
aber dann doch 75 prozent weniger
insekten drei viertel weniger
das sind wirklich beängstigende zahlen
und insekten sind so ziemlich die
wichtigste spezies auf unserem planeten
sie bestäuben pflanzen dienen vögeln und
anderen arten als wertvolle nahrung und
so weiter und so fort ein rückgang der
insekten hat über kurz oder lang
dramatische auswirkungen auf die erde
auf uns menschen in der zeitung die zeit
wurde das auf bemerkenswerte weise auf
den punkt gebracht zitat wenn wir
unserem ökosystem drei viertel des
fundaments wegschlagen
ist das ein massiver eingriff in die
natur ordnung
mit anderen worten das kann unsere erde
töten also zu einem massensterben führen
inklusive menschheit riesenproblem viele
insekten sind zudem mit bestimmten
pflanzen eine art symbiose eingegangen
sie leben voneinander stirbt das insekt
aus wird das auch die pflanze treffen
es wird eine schreckliche kettenreaktion
eintreten und sie hat ja schon begonnen
auch die vögel dezimieren sich in
deutschland durch das insekten sterben
und auch europaweit wir hatten ja im mai
darüber berichtet damals gab es eine so
genannte kleine anfrage im bundestag
ergebnis es sind 57 prozent weniger
tiere bei den brautpaaren in europa fast
zwei drittel und bestimmte vogelarten
trifft es besonders es gibt 80 prozent
weniger kiebitze die rebhühner sind vom
aussterben bedroht hier liegt der
rückgang sogar bei 84 prozent bedroht
sind weiter wachtel start turteltaube
gartenrotschwanz braunkehlchen und so
weiter und so fort
inklusive der vorwarnliste für vom
aussterben bedrohte brutvögel sind 87
prozent der arten die betroffen sind
fast 90 prozent das ist nah an alle
furchtbar wirklich wirklich stimmt wir
müssen unbedingt handeln die menschheit
muss handeln die gründe sind dabei sogar
ziemlich simpel zitat pestizide spielen
mit sicherheit eine ganz große rolle
wir können davon ausgehen dass es
besonders bei kleinen
naturschutzgebieten durch verfrachtung
über die luft zu einer kontamination der
fläche kommt ja das sagt jan christian
habel vom lehrstuhl für terrestrische
ökologie der tu münchen im zdf
wenn schon in naturschutzgebieten also
da wo überhaupt kann ich chemikalien
hinkommen sollen zu viele pestizide sind
dann heißt das dass in der
landwirtschaft also da wo sie angewendet
werden die alarmglocken schrillen müssen
und dabei könnte schnelles handeln
wirklich hier helfen zum thema es ist
eigentlich gar nicht so schlimm
die vergangenheit hat gezeigt dass sich
populationen sehr schnell wieder erholen
können wenn ihnen die chance gegeben
wird wenn sie allerdings einmal
ausgestorben sind dann ist es vorbei
und das droht dem moment pestizide
müssen dringend stärker kontrolliert
werden mehr mischkulturen biolandbau und
so weiter und so fort sind dringend
nötig und wir verbraucher können mit
unseren einkäufen abstimmen ist kostet
echt nicht so viel mehr gute bio
produkte und die vielleicht bewusster zu
essen statt fast food in sich rein
schauen man muss ja nicht päpstlicher
als der papst sein aber ein bisschen
bewussteres leben würde uns schon gut
tun und vor allem der natur also ran an
den speck verzeihung an die bio gurken
mehr infos gibt s übrigens beim
naturschutzbund deutschland demnach also
macht euch da mal schlau und zwar hier
genau draufklicken unbedingt und wenn er
kein video mehr zu diesem und zu allen
anderen leben verpassen wollt dann
drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergessen nicht den auf die glocke hier
geht es weiter mit dem video zum
vogelsterben das ist auch leider
ziemlich dramatisch tja und ansonsten
bis dann bleibt kann